Veterans Day was originally Armistice
Day. President Woodrow Wilson set the day
aside in 1919 to honor the troops who
served in World War I.
President Eisenhower expanded the
holiday to honor all living and still serving veterans.
One way that American
veterans have continued to serve has
been by being politically active — by
being elected to Congress and the presidency.
In the 2018 midterms, nearly
200 veterans ran for federal office
on election day. Veterans typically say
they want to join Congress to continue to
serve the public and to help protect our
democratic norms — through legislative,
rather than military, means. It's
important to have veterans in Congress.
They can bring a level of
defense expertise invaluable for shaping
national security policies. They tend to
ask more about when and how we use
military force; to conduct more oversight
of the executive branch; and to work to
see that the troops have the necessary
resources and training to operate
effectively and successfully. Having the
voice of veterans on the legislative "front lines"
is a substantive addition to our national debates.
What do you think veterans bring to
Congress? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.